On January 20th South Korea confirmed
its first case of kovat 19 the same day
the United States also confirmed its
first case of kovat 19 but what happened
next in both countries was really
different
this chart shows for several countries
the number of kovat 19 tests performed
relative to the population right away
South Korea started aggressively testing
for the virus before long it had
conducted more tests per thousand people
than any other country most experts say
that testing at that scale is the key to
safely opening public spaces we need to
test and trace we need more testing the
larger the outbreak you have of the
virus the more tests you should be doing
it's wise how Korea was able to avoid a
broad lockdown the u.s. was much slower
to ramp up their testing but eventually
in mid-april they caught up to South
Korea as of mid-may about three percent
of the US population had been tested for
kovin 18 and now some parts of the US
are starting to reopen but some experts
warn that in many of those places
reopening is premature that even though
the US has been doing a lot more testing
they haven't been testing the right
people
because South Korea ramped up testing so
quickly in those first few weeks they
were able to track down lots of people
who have the virus and isolate them so
that everyone else could go back to work
and most experts agree that if you send
people back to work without doing this
first it's really dangerous testing is
like response 101 it's the most obvious
thing we need to do in any disease
outbreak that's because if a country
doesn't test effectively they don't
really know where the virus is and how
many people have it so how do you know
if you are testing enough to avoid this
this chart shows for each of these
countries what percentage of all of
their Kovan 18 tests have come back
positive up until mid-may it's called
the test positivity rate this number
doesn't tell us what percentage of
people in each country have Kovan 18 but
you can think of it as an easy way to
see which countries are doing enough
testing to contain their outbreak we
would certainly like to see countries
testing at the level of 10 negative
tests 2 1 positive that's 10% in other
words the countries below this line have
done a better job testing and that's
because this number can tell us a lot
about who in the country is actually
getting tested and how well we know
about this diseases or a lot of people
who have very mild symptoms would have
actually no symptoms at all and we're
almost really not testing those people
in the u.s. Kovan 19 tests were in short
supply for a long time and that shaped
the Center for Disease Control's
guidelines on how health care workers
should allocate testing prioritize
people showing up to hospitals with the
most severe symptoms if that's where
testing is focused it makes sense that a
large portion of people tested will test
positive but it also means you are
missing anyone who isn't actively
seeking out those tests this is a
reactive testing scenario it's probably
what happened in other countries with
high test positivity rates and to
understand why that matters we can look
at countries that also experienced a big
outbreak but have a lower test
positivity rate like Australia
in South Korea instead of narrowly
focusing on testing the very sick these
countries tested proactively they tested
a much wider group of people including
many who didn't feel sick at all they're
testing lots and lots of people and
they're probably picking up everybody
that led to a lot of negative results
which drove their positive rate lower
and because they tested so many people
their tests didn't only find people with
severe symptoms but also those with mild
symptoms and even many who tested
positive that had no symptoms at all and
these are the people who are key to
containing an outbreak if someone
doesn't feel very sick it's unlikely
they will seek out a test which means
you have to find them and when testing
is only reserved for the sickest these
people who do feel sick often don't make
the cut supervising the lighter and so I
didn't get tested because of that I
developed a dry cough and I called my
doctor I'm also pregnant so I called my
prenatal care tape you know doctor as
well and they both said no to getting
the test that they didn't have access to
it but I didn't qualify right off the
bat they told me okay
we're gonna assume you have it and we're
not going to test you if you chart the
United States test positivity rate over
time you can see it's been going down
which could be a sign the u.s. is
starting to test more effectively but if
you break it out by state you can see
that some places still have a long way
to go in a reactive testing scenario the
severely symptomatic people may have
gotten tested but the mildly symptomatic
and the asymptomatic are mingling with
people who don't have Cova 19 to find
those people and lower the test
positivity rate there are two options
one approach is to cast the net wide and
randomly test as many people as possible
if you just blanket the country with
tests
anybody who wakes up every morning every
other day if you want to go get a test
you can get a test every time you go to
work you can get a test asymptomatic
people are getting picked up just by the
fact that everybody's getting
this would require a huge increase in
testing in the first week of May the US
was averaging about 260,000 tests a day
but a random testing approach could
require tens of millions of daily tests
the other approach requires less testing
but is more targeted starting with the
people we already know tested positive
for code 19 you isolate them but you
also talk to them at all their contacts
everybody they have spent any time and
then you go test all those people and
some of them are gonna be asymptomatic
and you're gonna pick up asymptomatic
disease through contactors experts like
dr. JA say that approach would require
more like 900 thousand daily tests but
in both scenarios the goal is the same
the entire math of this comes down to
one simple idea you want to keep
infected people away from susceptible
that's safely transitioning out of
social distancing requires finding out
where the virus is and who has it that
means testing and it's why if you want
to know if your country or state or city
is doing a good job containing its
outbreak its test positivity rate is a
good place to look because the
difference between opening back up with
a low test positivity rate and a high
one is the difference between caution
and just hoping for the best
[Music]